on aimerait faire un petit jeu avec toi
si tu veux te mettre un casque eux voilà
c'est un casque avec des musiques
françaises que je kiffe d'accord je te
propose un petit défi tu vas devoir
essayer de faire retrouver aux
téléspectateurs ce que tu en train de
chanter
d'accord c'est que des trucs que je
kiffe moi à oui d'accord vous essayez de
trouver c'est le glas de mireille c'est
dj mireille attention c'est parti
premier titre j'ai vu le clip inscrit à
dudule dans le prénom alors
[Applaudissements]
mettez la croix metella 3 lacroix soit
mais c'est bon c'est parce que tu aimes
si c'est parce que tu es toi ses hits
préférés système bien hein c'est quoi
mais croque photo chanter bien présentes
et sauf si tu étais pas d un petit peu
vas-y eu un passé compliqué la donne à
ma main je sais que c'est à la chanson
préfère moi j'aime bien malheureux nahd
mais c'est quoi
non c'est quoi tu sais quoi
je t'enfonce dans votre ennemi ces
particules à champéry
c'est parti la carte bazille c'est un
comble ce la musique grand remettre un
sarde à rodez 1 5 ha vas-y vas-y vas-y
mammeri que nous aujourd'hui ce que tu
écoutes avec fait 18 chez vous faites le
champ clos pourquoi on essaie de
découvrir
[Rires]
[Musique]
allez y ça là et c'est tout là et je
t'ai vu la chanter pour qu'on essaie de
trouver attention c'est parti ça là
allez vas-y la dernière la 5 et sera la
dernière
vas-y vas-y lalala lalala lalala lalala
[Musique]
c'est quoi gt ça
[Applaudissements]